I think I was known as to being quite an
odd guy at Uni anyway and just doing
things because they were funny and then
I just got so lucky one day where I
walked past Zach allsop on the street
who was a fellow YouTuber at the time
who had about 30 000 subscribers at the
time and I said to him look mate if you
if you ever need a cameraman for
anything let me know but I said to Zach
oh yeah I make videos as well I've got
like 18 million views on my videos and
he weirdly said yeah actually well we're
filming something tomorrow do you want
to come and help film so I helped film
there and then he had this idea to kind
of break me into London Fashion Week
dressed up as a model and we did that
and then that's just kind of like boom
just went straight
I don't think I do enough to combat
burnouts I do therapy that was one of
the first things that I bought with some
YouTube money was like therapy but then
it all boils down to like ideas of like
self-esteem I've kind of got to kind of
a an impasse where I know the things
that make me feel bad when it comes to
like negative thoughts when it comes to
video making and like have big numbers
but the goal posts just move daily I
don't think I've ever said this publicly
but
hey friends welcome back to Deep dive
the weekly podcast where every week it
is my immense privilege to sit down with
academics and authors and entrepreneurs
and creators and other inspiring people
and we find out how they got to where
they are and the strategies and tools we
can learn from them to help live our own
best lives now what you're about to hear
is an interview that I've just done with
Max fosh Max is a YouTuber and stand-up
comedian you might have seen a video
which now has 30 million views where he
and our friends at Zach and Jay they
faked him as a model to the top of
London Fashion Week wearing like a
garbage bag or something like that
recently he's also gone viral for
playing a prank where he convinced
people landing at Gatwick Airport that
they were landing at Luton Airport
instead he famously ran for mayor of
London a couple years ago he has gotten
an official presidential pardon for a
crime that he committed in 2009 and he
seems to have built a career off the
back of being an internet prankster kind
of vibe anyway this is a sick
conversation we talk about how he became
disillusioned with the world of
Corporations and like big corporate and
a real job and we we talk about his
journey through University how getting
involved in student radio ultimately led
to him doing silly things on the
internet and making silly videos now to
the point where his YouTube channel is
at nearly 1.5 million subscribers he's
building his own team he's just done a
whole stand-up proper show thing at the
Edinburgh Fringe and is performing at
the London Palladium Theater which is
this huge venue in about two months and
me and the team are going to be getting
tickets to that anyway I hope you
enjoyed this conversation with Max vosh
by the way just a flag um we actually
had a bit of an audio issue for the
first five or so minutes of this episode
we've kept him in because it's top
banter and Max is like really freaking
funny and like yeah but please excuse
the audio for the first five minutes it
gets really good beyond that point
you've been described as lots of things
I'm really interested to know what
you're going to describe me as because
is it going to be prankster because
that's normally the number one that
people go oh so I was gonna ask you how
you describe yourself but I the line
from the video where I first discovered
it was uh Zach and Jay's Fashion Week
one surprisingly 30 million views we've
baked a model fake model to talk about
yeah they describe to you as we need a
confident unfashionable blank canvas of
a man
yeah that was I feel like that's a
reasonable I think that's probably yeah
that's probably quite fair from from
zappy J
um yeah I think I think I get a lot of I
get a lot of prankster which I don't
massively love
um I I get a lot of what do you do
that's mainly from my like close family
and friends a lot of my family friends
still think I make radio but I still
think I do radio because I started off
like being a radio presenter yeah one of
your like internet bios says broadcaster
before YouTuber when we were doing a
research it was like Max watch is a
broadcaster that they think broadcast
yeah I don't yeah I just don't think the
kind of mainstream doesn't know what
they just kind of panic and they're like
okay what do we call this guy so uh I
think content creator is probably the uh
the best the best the best fitting one
yeah so your your story is a somewhat
circuitous and like interesting so I
wonder if we can just sort of stop stop
there um
from understanding about 10 years ago
2013 you started an internship and
that's always your hatred of the
corporate world yes what was going on
there yeah I I kind of grew up in in a
very kind of a privileged bubble and I
went to a school called Harrow school
which is a very well-known Posh private
school here in the UK and
I I don't want to I don't want to say I
don't want to kind of like bad mouth the
school
um and so they this wasn't something
that was actively being kind of pushed
but there was a feeling I felt of like
right you go into certain Avenues in a
career so that's law or Finance or
medicine and finance definitely was one
of the big ones in my father worked in
insurance and so when I was 17 I got the
kind of very nepotistic opportunity to
to go and sit and just I observe which I
found is a really interesting way of
like uh prefacing an internship going to
observe like you're 17. you have no idea
what's going on I sat there for a week
and I thought is this it is is this
but we were all aware that this is the
thing that everyone is so excited about
and I kind of got very kind of
disenfranchised the idea that I was
going to go and work in the city or work
in in finance so like I've I've never
worked a corporate job what was it like
it was everyone so you get in uh you
don't really your house how's your you
know good thanks mate you're nice for
two hours don't say anything
one stale bit of banter gets floated
around without the correct that's coming
30 minutes late with some ketchup down
this top of
big breakfast Greg yeah and then tap tap
tap and I was then sent I was then sent
to fetch the pies at lunch and that was
my favorite part of the day so that's
why I got to actively do something I got
really excited to go get the pies
um and came back and then some more
snail banter about Greg and then and
then after work drinks where people
would get uh pissed and they'd go home
like I'd just like the preface this
isn't the entire uh existence of people
who live in the courtroom this was just
my uh experience in the week that I was
working there at 17. and that's I kind
of realized as much for I I want
something that was much more creatively
fulfilling and so when I went to
University I I changed my course within
the first three or four months from
economics and finance to English
literature and this is kind of the one
of the first times I I realized I was
probably quite good at lagging something
because I hadn't done English at a level
and so I walked into the English school
and said I'd like to do your degree
please and they said okay what did you
earn your own English a level I said I
didn't do it and they said okay whether
we can't offer you a a place an English
school and I remember I said for some
reason but what if I get a 2-1 in my
first year in economics that surely
proves that I'm a good student so I'd be
I'd be value to your to your um school I
think she was so taken aback the head of
English that she just said yeah okay
fine deal and I ended up getting a T1 in
my first year of Economics so then that
made me do English literature and so
that was suddenly I was terrible I was
terrible leadership but it meant I was
suddenly doing things that were slightly
more creative okay so like age 19 you
sort of find your way into English
literature yeah as a degree yeah what
happens next in the math so in I was
then just try I was just joining
societies I was just like super
interested and excited going from this
very
institutionalized world of Harrow where
you get up at a certain time every day
and you do this and you do this and you
do this into like meeting loads of
different people from loads of different
backgrounds and doing things that I
never I probably would have had the
opportunity to do at Harrow but it would
be very regimented so I suddenly
realized I could have my own radio show
like during the theater Society I joined
something called the 20-minute society
which is where they take your number and
at any point throughout the week they'll
text you with an activity and you need
to be there in 20 minutes you have to
drop everything you're doing and I love
this like spontaneous like nature of of
university life and so I was trying
those different things and I understood
oh I really like entertaining people
whether that's on stage with the theater
Society or broadcasting or basically
just being able to talk interrupted for
an hour on the radio and so I did
student radio which then led me to
hospital radio in Newcastle I did that
for three years four years okay the The
Internship yes
um what was it like so I kind of I
arrived in this kind of corporate world
at 17 uh working in kind of I think it
was Trading
and I kind of was was really shocked at
how this was it this was the thing that
we've been kind of told okay yeah or not
necessarily by the institutional or
teachers but just by like peers and
Pierce parents yeah this is the Pinnacle
this is the Pinnacle like you work in
the city you get to work in Lloyds and
go to go to bank station in your in your
pinstripe suit every day and get you get
your prep subscription coffee here we go
lad strapping and then afterwards you
have a couple of pints at the pub and
you have some very stale conversation
um and so I kind of spent this week just
being told to go and get pies and to
just observe I remember I I did actually
get into a relatively confrontational
conversation with somebody because
someone said to me you're not doing
anything this is an opportunity that so
many people would kill to do you're not
concentrating what we're doing I said I
don't know what you're doing just give
me something to do and actually that did
work because then I was tasked with
putting together the newsletter that um
the people would come into the office
every morning and see the newsletter
from the night before the parks in in
Asia so I was getting in at 3 4 AM uh to
to write up what would happen in the
markets and send them to people's
inboxes at 8am which they 100 sent
straight to junk
um and then I got to leave at like two
or three but my point was is that I it
was just not it wasn't what I I wasn't
creatively fulfilled and I thought right
let's go and try and see if there's
anything else and so that when I went to
University I like really made sure that
I'm gonna get my head down and just try
loads of different things nice we were
talking about student radio like what is
student radio student radio is
essentially a cupboard which has some
foam on the walls a microphone that
doesn't work and some students thinking
that they are Nick Grimshaw for for an
hour of every single day and the idea is
that some some student radios are better
than others like some of them are really
good Sunderland have one called spark
that is genuinely its own FM station so
it broadcasts in Newcastle oh sorry in
Sunderland
um whereas Newcastle when I was there
it wasn't very good most the time the
broadcast output just wasn't it wouldn't
work so you you wouldn't actually be
broadcasting to anybody see just be
talking in this microphone yeah exactly
in a cupboard in a Cupboard and you
could listen to it online I think but
often that wouldn't work and
remember they had a real humbling
experience they had a listener counter I
found out there was a listen account
about two or three shows in and I logged
on and I saw there were three people
listening and I knew that two I knew two
of those people because I asked them and
sent them the link so
um it was just an opportunity for me to
try
just being a radio presenter and like
come out with your own show and writing
your own show what are the segments okay
getting some outside outside broadcast
stuff and Vox pops and
um and so I did that for about a year
and I realized there's no there's no
progression here you're just I'm just
coming in and doing the same thing every
week and so luckily I looked into and
found Hospital radio which
um in Newcastle when I was there or
still is the the hostel station there
called radio tineside was really well
run and it was quite well funded I think
a radio station that's being broadcast
in the hospital yes so in hospitals you
have five buttons
um I think not in all hospitals but a
lot of them so five buttons of radio
stations so there's Radio One radio four
Classic FM magic and then normally the
local station which is hostel radio
um and so we had radio tines I was
broadcasting to the six hospitals I
think in the Newcastle and gateshead
area so we had quite like a large
listener base
um and yeah I guess the patient's in bed
threw up yeah choosing to not go for
radio one I mean yeah I mean it's quite
slim pickings it's kind of almost is
kind of this like hostage situation
where you're always forcing to listen to
you but
um I I worked there for three years and
started on the overnight shift of like 2
a.m till 4am and then work my way up and
when I left my last year I was doing the
breakfast show so what does that look
like like what does your two to four a.m
shift and Hospital radio look like
luckily a lot of it could be
pre-recorded so you could uh
they would like you to do a few live
shows
um but you could go in and pre-record
the entire thing
um and obviously there wouldn't be any
interaction with the patients but
they're kind of rarely was when you're
in hospital you're not exactly like
picking up the phone it's texting it
especially at two in the morning exactly
um so it's it just kind of like was any
other radio station in the sense it was
the same software
um and you just kind of you so are you
playing music yeah just a minute or
you're playing music you're playing
music which is easy listening music
which has been pre-programmed into the
computer but as I was there for longer I
realized that I could like swap things
out and no one would really notice
um I then did get in trouble because I
once had a few complaints because I
played the song Highway to Hell
um on hostile radio and I didn't need to
get slacked
um but and what was what was funny is I
was I was brought up not on the fact the
the title and the content of the song
broadcast also radio a bit more the fact
that it wasn't easy listening
um and so yeah you're playing music
you're playing like three or four tracks
and then you get like a minute or 45
seconds of whatever you want to talk
about and then repeat it's almost two
hours what is that so it's it's been
it's been years since I've listened to
like a music radio station so what does
what does the the stuff in between the
songs like what would you be saying it
could be it could be anything generally
I'm like oh it's a lovely day today yeah
two or four in the morning here at times
yeah or normally that's when like
segments are quite important or you kind
of every hour you have to do one of
those needs to be what's on in Newcastle
this week so you get given like a little
booklet okay then we see okay this
person's playing at the time theater
opera house and this person this person
I don't know why you're like to
broadcast that because these people are
in hospital and they're not exactly like
keeping cats and Live Comedy yeah
um but then the rest of it is you can do
whatever you like so I did a lot of like
voxpop stuff so I would go out what does
that mean so I would go interview people
on the street oh so previously I would
go out interview people get some content
edit it together and then put it in that
segment so it's like so last week in
Newcastle I went out to go find out
whether people thought there were more
eyes or legs in the world and then just
okay
so I was kind of creating these like one
minute long segments that I would then
like put in and I was obsessed with this
idea that's when I read I want to go
into radio I want to be a radio
presenter
um and I'd seen the career progression
of all these kind of like my Idols in
the in the radio world they had all done
the hospital radio and then they'd won
this award at the Hostile broadcasting
Association awards which is like it's
the big nights in the hospital radio
calendar uh
um and it was I was at the best newcome
and I won best Newcastle here we go come
on offers let's see radio one I'm free
to to do a show and none came I I got
one offer of a demo for BBC Radio
Newcastle and I remember it was kind of
a moment where I realized I wasn't going
to be a radio presenter because I walked
in and they they were like great okay
Max we can get you to do a demo
um fantastic okay just talk about
whatever you want as if it's your own
show
and all the other voices on boobs you
read a Newcastle like welcome back to
BBC Radio Newcastle fantastic local
radio for the Northeast and we've got
Max here this afternoon I'm like Hello
nice to see you all and it's safe to say
that I didn't get the job
um of local radio in the Northeast with
the the plummiest accent
um so I that's when I kind of realized
oh I'm not really gonna get a job in
radio in the places that I would really
like to get one so you didn't want radio
for no I mean yeah maybe but that I was
I was look after some some excitement
and seduce like silly things and okay
yeah not yet it will be in a couple of
years but not not at the age of like 21.
um so that's when I just kind of started
doing I realized that I had loads of
radio stuff I didn't have any like video
stuff and I was obsessed with this idea
of getting an agent I don't know why I
thought once you get an agent you are
sorted like everything's okay so I
thought okay to make a show real but I
don't have any video stuff so I then
thought right let's do just man on the
street content like interviewing people
I was in Newcastle lots of students on
nights out let's go chat to them and I
reached out to the TV society that was
doing their own show a TV Society yeah
is that a university a society that
makes like television and they were
doing their own version of this called
Big Market banter and they are a player
I applied to be I applied to be a
presenter on Big Market banter and they
said no sorry we've got all our
presenters at the moment so I was like
well great I mean it's in public I can
just go do it myself so I filmed uh five
episodes of me just interviewing people
on nights out and put them on Facebook
and
people were tagging their mates or Ali
or a little can't believe that person
said that so funny or look where he is
and it kind of starts doing quite well
in the sense of like a thousand people
in my University would see it and I kind
of and people oh you should keep doing
them and I was like okay I guess I will
so then for my last year at University I
was just every single week I would go
out and make a new video on a different
topic and go back edit the videos and
and put it up onto Facebook Okay lots of
questions on this yeah how did you have
the confidence to just do this uh was it
the just was it like just the way you
were born was it the private school was
it like what I guess
like I am inherently bit of a show off
yeah and very extroverted and I like
talking to people and I was
yeah I
I just saw what it was being done so the
big Market Bank I was watching this and
I saw there were 18 minute long episodes
these things and I remember the first
minute would be hi guys welcome back to
the show super excited
um Harry and Becky here so today we're
gonna be going out and interviewing and
I remember thinking I'm so bored already
um and I was watching at the same time
people like kasm G
um on YouTube
um over in the states and like this guy
is really funny I want to make my own
stuff like this and so it was mainly
just
the answer I've had dude like how do I
have the confidence to do it I just I
just kind of didn't really think
anything of it and I think that's
probably very lucky the upbringing I had
Harrow very much instilled this like
confidence this assumed confidence in in
like things that I did and like because
with when you first get there the first
thing you have to do is like do a song
in front of your whole boarding house oh
so like you're 13 and you have to sing a
song you have to sing a song in front of
80 boys so it's the the the house song
oh so yeah like one at a time one at a
time wow and so even if you can sing if
you can't sing like you I was constantly
being thrown into situations like that
where eventually you get very very
comfortable with like uncomfortable
situations and getting through an
outside of your comfort zone and so I
guess that's how I had that confidence
yeah and I was just a show off fair play
and so what what sort of stuff were you
asking these people on nights out I was
just copying what I'd seen on YouTube so
initially I remember a video that I
watched was one this this uh antibody
and Muse Channel
um did where they said Americans are not
stupid they went out to America and
there are some really easy Journal
language questions and it went hugely
viral I remember watching this this
video over and over again because this
is amazing it's my like basically my
face because it was like it was like
really basic questions yeah it was like
name the country beginning with you yeah
and it's like Yugoslavia and they're
like what about the United States of
America oh God Damon I hadn't thought of
it and so Jenny in my first video was me
just asking those questions yeah
um and so that's and then and I was
thinking of like Concepts one was called
Cards Against Humanity where I was just
taking the questions the prompts from
Cards Against Humanity and just getting
answers from people on the street like
it wasn't particularly uh difficult
um Pakistan how are you filming yourself
did you have like a camera
are you just kind of like
this have kind of got my first employees
I go for Coco like they're just friends
of mine it's like does anyone want to go
out and hold the camera with me for two
hours on a night out and eventually I
found this girl called Coco and she was
like Keen she's like yeah that sounds
fun so then she starts filming like all
of the beginning uh that I wasn't paying
her I wasn't getting paid no one was
getting paid but it was just like oh
right uni this is a fun thing to do
um and so that's how I managed to get
the first person involved
um yeah just a quick note from one of
our sponsors and we'll get right back to
the episode and very excitingly this
episode is brought to you by Heights
Heights is a brain care smart supplement
that I've actually been taking for the
last 12 months ever since I became
friends with Dan mariserto who was the
founder of heights and who we had on the
podcast in season one and this season of
the podcast we're also featuring Dr Tara
swart who is a neuroscientist and
psychiatrist so what is Heights well
it's a brain care smart supplement
basically it is a supplement you take
two of them every morning like I do it's
like these two little capsules which
have omega-3 oil in them and they've got
a bunch of multi vitamins as well they
have all of the details on the website
it's every single ingredient that
they've got is super high quality and
the great thing is that just by taking
two of these capsules every morning like
I do you get all of the essential
micronutrients that you need without
having to deal with drinking sludge or
anything fancy like that so the great
thing about Heights is that even if you
don't have one of these absolutely
perfect diets at least you know you have
your bases covered in terms of the
micronutrients that you need it's very
easy to sign up you just go to
yourheights.com and then you sign up to
the thing and it's a mail order they get
to you every month or in three month
packets and if you use the coupon code
Ali 15 that's ali15 at checkout then
you'll get 15 off your first three
months of subscription I've been
subscribed to this for the last 12
months I also happen to be an investor
in the company because I believe in the
product and I love how they're fully
evidence-based and absolutely everything
they do and if you're interested in the
evidence base behind all like 20
different ingredients that they've got
here you can check them out on the
website and that'll be linked in the
video description and in the show notes
so thank you so much to Heights for
sponsoring this episode you and Coco
going on nights out sticking a
microphone or like a phone in front of
people yeah and asking them questions
and then splicing it in together to like
a four minute vid okay and tracking on
Facebook yeah okay I'll do that for a
year I did I did that for 18 months and
this is why you're doing Hospital radio
on the side yeah so still doing Hospital
radio is that a paid gig by the way
Hospital radio no oh so that was all so
we're doing two to four am shift
Hospital radio just purely out of the
goodness of your heart yeah because it
was like it was it was exciting it was
fun like you suddenly had this big
studio and like buttons and you could
basically say whatever you liked as long
as you didn't like he was like
um so yeah I was doing a lot of and that
that formed so much of it gave me such a
big head start on what everything what
what I now have on YouTube and I always
say to people who they're like oh I want
to start something I was like do it in a
period of your life where the risk is so
low like if it failed if I didn't put
out a video it was fine because I could
still go back to my friends and my
family oh I don't do my degree like I'm
but I'm doing this bit on the side and
so I had that 18 months where I was at
Uni or three years of radio where there
was no pressure for it to do well or
succeed because I was you know I was
also doing a degree yeah I think that's
one of the issues whenever the bar is
hot is is high and it's like I often
find people who have success in some
area of life either it's at Uni or it's
in their jobs or something and then they
want to start a YouTube channel now all
of a sudden there's this like high
pressure pressure on it and I'm like oh
this has to succeed otherwise I'm a
failure otherwise I suck dot yeah and it
needs it needs to work instantly which
is not not how YouTube works I mean
you can you can kind of hack the system
and you can know retention tactics and
those kind of thing but
um I think it takes time for you to
understand what you're good at what you
provide the best value in it's you it's
education educating people and me I
think it's entertaining people but if I
decided to start an education Channel or
a kind of a wellness Channel I wouldn't
know what the weather it would take me
those two years to understand what I was
doing okay so you're checking these
videos on Facebook what sort of response
are you getting from people in the in
the uni scene I was just known as you're
that interview guy okay yeah um and it
was doing it was like it was doing quite
well I mean
um just within that sphere and
um it was kind of giving me the the the
social clout that I thought was quite
fun at the time and if as I was doing
more of them and if I was on the night
out with my microphone and my camera
like I would have people who are really
Keen to to chats and they want to be on
the videos and that was really really
cool to think that in like two or three
months I'd grown something that
previously I was like begging people can
you be on the like can you chat to me
for two minutes so then suddenly people
like oh yeah there's that guy
um but I think I was known as for being
quite a quite a an odd guy at Uni anyway
and just doing things because they were
funny
um I remember my my first year realizing
my Halls of residence that my desk in my
my room was the exact width of the lift
um in the halls of residence and so one
evening at midnight Me and My Maids we
didn't go out but we just moved my desk
into the lift with my laptop my books my
plants my lights and I would then like
work but my back was to the to the
entrance of the lift and so like the
lift doors would open at one in the
morning
get out of my room
and so I got to I got known as I known
as I left a boy for for a bit at Uni um
but my point is that I was doing lots of
these weird things because they were
funny and I enjoyed doing them but I
wasn't even filming them
um so yeah that was my unique experience
and so your English degree was a bit of
a side hustle while you were doing all
this stuff absolutely I I did terribly
badly in my English literature degree um
because I wasn't interested in in
writing about Chaucer yeah I was I was
thinking about what was what were the
questions that were going to be tonight
when I was going to ask students on like
that just a quick message from one of
our sponsors and we'll get right back to
the episode and this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
that summarizes books but it's way more
than just book summaries they almost
have a whole study guide for every book
that they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books and
lifestyle and communication basically
any genre of like non-fiction personal
development is self-helpy stuff that
will help you level up your life it's
all there on short form short form
Publishers new book guides and articles
every week and if you're a subscriber
then you get to vote on what book they
cover next and in fact through that
system I have voted for various books
that they've then turned into summaries
for example one of the book guides I
read recently was how to take smart
notes by songki RNs which is a book that
I've read in its entirety a handful of
times but I've read the short form
summary of the book even more than that
because I've been using that to revisit
the key lessons from the book and that
feeds into my own system for personal
Knowledge Management anyway if any of
that sounds up your street and you would
like to sign up to the world's best
service that summarizes books then head
over to shortform.com forward slash deep
dive and that will give you a complete
free five-day trial and you can try out
the service to your heart's content that
link will also be in the video
description and in the show notes and
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode okay so what
happened next you're doing Hospital
radio you're doing the Facebook video
version of interviews yeah what's what's
what happens next I graduate uni I went
on a self-proclaimed tour with street
smart with this this video series
um and I thought okay this is my one
chance I'm gonna like go all or nothing
so two weeks I drove around the country
with Coco and every night we would go to
a new University City so let's say we
started in Bristol we'd film in Bristol
yeah in the evening go to bed I'd wake
up I'd edit the Bristol video from the
night before uh post it drive to Exeter
film and Exeter go to bed edit externs
we did this for two weeks so we did 14
cities and 14. and at this point are you
on YouTubers are still Facebook well it
was being posted on YouTube but they
were getting like 200 views on YouTube
yeah
um and I was posting these on Facebook
and I I really thought right after this
two weeks like things are going to blow
up because of the consistency of it all
and here we go and I didn't I've done
this two weeks killed myself like I
hadn't lost a lot of money on petrol
that kind of thing and I was a bit
dejected and I didn't really know what
the whole I was like what's the point of
this I kind of had this thing at
University it was working but it hasn't
really like pushed on and I then worked
in a pub for about three or four months
I'm still making the videos I was still
kind of like still still going and then
I just got so lucky one day where I
walked past Zach allsop on the streets
who was a better YouTuber at the time
who had about 30 000 subscribers at the
time okay and I watched him and I was a
fan of him yeah and I said to him look
come here if you if you ever need a
cameraman for anything let me know and I
had been lucky with my with my uh
Facebook videos that I've been reposted
one of my videos have been reposted by a
big Channel called student problems and
it got like 18 million views on student
problems is uh on on their page
um I didn't see a shot of that Revenue
that's beside the point cheer student
problems um but I said to Zach uh oh
yeah I make videos as well I've got like
18 million views on my video right
they're just purely just trying to like
Flex as much as I could like give me a
joke give me a job and he weirdly said
yeah actually while we're filming
something tomorrow do you want to come
and help film so I help film there and
got to know him a little bit better
and over the course of like three or
four months we kind of did more work to
get the more I was still working the pub
and then he had this idea to kind of
break me into London Fashion Week
dressed up as a model
um and we did that and then that's just
kind of like boom just went
stratospheric yeah so what was that like
it was
um and if you can give some context for
people yeah so the video was
um it was a basically a a total rip-off
of a video that Uber Butler had made
about two years previously he was a guy
who worked worked at Vice and he managed
to to fake a fashion brand into Fashion
Week by getting people to talk about it
and so we had the idea of like we're
gonna dress me up in ridiculous clothing
so we went to Primark we bought like
maternity trousers Zach had like some
shoes that he'd been given when he'd
spent a night in jail for breaking into
the EMA so I was wearing I was wearing
jail shoes maternity trousers like I had
a rug on my sofa that we pinned in weird
places we then got like plastic
packaging that you get in like Parcels
the big pillow ones and wrap them round
my neck like some sort of like Royal
rough and we just went uh we were just
went to Fashion Week and we got Coco who
was actually still working with me at
the time to like trigger the flash on on
her camera and just shout my name
here and like immediately loads of
photographers like ran over started
taking pictures asking who I was and
then Zach pretended to be my manager and
it just kind of snowballs the point
where like we then sent those photos to
the shows the next day being like we've
got this new hot model he's making a
real scene like you should get him into
your shows we've got invites to shows he
got invited to After parties
um and we made this video documentary in
this process well Zach did post it on
his channel
and I remember talking to my dad before
it went live saying
I'll be really happy if I get a thousand
subscribers out of this video
um and my dad was like just just be like
just be careful you don't know could
nothing could happen it's okay and
almost immediately the video when the
video went out it just exploded in a way
that I haven't seen a video do like that
yeah like 30 million views or something
now like but it was yeah and and so we I
went from 1800 subscribers to 80 000
subscribers in about four days because
he linked to your channel and things
yeah my channel was linked and I was
thinking I was a big part of the video
yeah um and so I guess people like oh
yeah this guy seems cool yeah check this
guy out and they went from 30 000
subscribers to 300 000 subscribers in
five days which was just yeah mad
um and so what I quite what I quite like
is Zach is still like probably one of my
best mates uh and we are both really
kind of proud of the fact that our
career trajectory is both kind of like
really entwined in the sense that we
both kind of blew up with the same video
at the same time
um and so from there I realized oh okay
I've suddenly got this audience yeah
um and did I and I didn't do anything
different I just went back to making the
same street interviews and like oh great
I've got no no more people are watching
but let's just do straight into these
again and that was really stupid what
was it about that video that you think
hit it off so well
the storytelling is phenomenal from Zach
like the edit that he made is absolutely
incredible um I think as well it's it's
the victim of the prank is the fashion
industry and that's a I think that's a
communal shared victim that people kind
of don't feel too sorry about
um a lot of those videos I do I'm always
thinking okay is this punching up or is
this punching down
um and I think it's really important to
think about that when you are doing the
kind of content that I make because
otherwise it can very quickly feel
quite vindictive or or just not very
nice
um
I don't I genuinely don't know I don't
know why that video has done so well
um it's just one that just and so how
did it feel seeing the numbers climb on
that video what was yours in like Zach's
reaction were you like on the phone to
be like oh my God it was dangerously
addictive yeah it was like I remember
like genuinely just like the cat the the
rat in the experiment were like clicking
for for more food like I was just a
refreshing YouTube Studio every two
minutes just watching the numbers
um and it was yeah it was incredibly
exciting and
awesome but then it fades so quickly
like a week later and you're like okay
now what now what yeah I'm just gonna
make the same stuff that I have always
done and then so like while you were
while you were there in in Fashion Week
doing sort of holding like uh your uh uh
haughty pose and and stuff yeah what was
going through your mind like how how was
that for you I was terrified I was
genuinely terrified because I got like
I was a very good student at school I
always did what I was told like I got my
homework in on time this idea of kind of
breaking the narrow breaking the molds
and doing something a bit cheeky or
naughty was something that was like
completely alien to me but I was
determined to do it for that video
because I knew the opportunity would be
it would bring by being on Zach and
Jay's Channel um so I was very I'm
pushing myself outside of my comfort
zone massively also
um the the costume that we had made we'd
put together with safety pins and one of
the safety pins had come undone whilst
we're filming and so it was generally
had a safety pin in my back so one of
them was like stuck in me and so I was
in quite a lot of pain so the faces of
just kind of like total disdain towards
everyone was purely because I was in
quite a lot of pain
um so I think I was just it was like
let's just get this over and done with
it's nearly done it's nearly over okay
um and it's I've now come to view this
this feeling of like I call it the 10
seconds of Terror and on the other side
of 10 seconds of Terror is is something
that's really exciting and really fun
and something that you you couldn't
possibly imagine so I always think if
I'm ever I'm doing less and less of
these these videos where
I'm like pushing myself to go into
extreme circumstances if I have ever in
that scenario I just think it's okay 10
seconds of Terror it will be done soon
okay so you've got at this point you've
just exploded onto London Fashion Week
you've got your 80 000 subscribers what
what happens next
I've um so that was in March 2019 yeah
then for the next year until March 2020
I just genuinely just kept making more
Street Smart videos I just went out and
just interviewing again people on nights
out or people at events that I went to
the World Wife Carrying championships
and interview people there and I moved
more into like conventions
um that was my idea of like branching
out
and then covert hits and I was a mess
because I was like this my whole job
revolves around me interviewing people
so what was the channel monetized at
that point and the channel
a little bit of both between like still
working the pub and and doing but the
channel was basically monetized at that
point and Coco was still working with me
and like for free or fun like we were
getting like we were sharing 50 of the
channel each okay which I remember like
looking back on it now like seems mad
but we I just wanted to do this so I
wasn't really thinking about like the
split of it and and how it was going to
work
um and so it was definitely not big
enough channel to be able to be like
supporting two people two people's wages
um
so covet hit and I said what I'm going
to do uh I can't interview people it's
my whole bread and butter
and that's when I started to make
different types of videos so there was a
there was a stock photo in my flat that
I had never it was in a frame that I've
been bought I'd never bothered to change
out the stock photo and so I thought and
I'd never never change so she'd become
this woman has become like part of my
flat for two years could have been too
lazy to change her outfit a photo of my
family or whatever and so I then just I
remember sitting there like in lockdown
board I was like I wonder who she is
I'd have to talk to her that'd be cool
so I then spent this series this like
three-part series of like trying to find
the woman from the stock photo and
initially I thought it was gonna be like
a one I thought it was gonna be really
easy I thought I was gonna put it in
reverse image search it she's gonna be a
popular model reach out to her see if I
can talk to her but it ended up being
this like real goose chase like I was
going it took me six weeks to by talking
to experts and stock photography
um experts and and like data analysts
and and people who worked in archives at
Getty Images it's like do you know this
person is you know this style and I
eventually found this I found this this
model
and that really people really enjoyed
that series and I realized okay maybe I
can do more storytelling bits rather
than just shoving a microphone in front
of someone's face and trying to get them
to say something silly and that's where
so covered was kind of a blessing and
was the best thing that could have
happened but although I totally lost my
mind and was worried that it was the end
of all YouTube
it meant that it forced myself to to try
a different angle of video making and
yeah okay and so presumably you're
living at home at this point working in
the pub part time but pubs weren't
really a thing no I was I think it was
furloughed uh I can't remember I had
left the pub at this point I think I'd
left the pub just before covert I seem
to remember I think I think I remember
thinking okay I've just got this
situation where I just I I can just
about you know
um make this make this work I mean I've
also got to preferences as well I I knew
that I would be okay if I failed as well
I came for I come from a background of
immense privilege and I knew that it
would be okay but I know that I need to
work hard at this the insurance company
is always there exactly I can go I can
go go with you internships um if if
needs be yeah um so but if anything that
that kind of like that was a real
driving force to me you really want to
go to work work work harder for it okay
so you start this this foray into the
world of lens storytelling type videos
um so what happened next what was that I
then just since covert have just been
steadily making more and more they're
going bigger and bigger and I've
realized that with YouTube You're often
referred to as the guy or girl that does
blank so if people would come say hello
in the street and they're with their
mate it would be oh you're the guy that
does
XYZ and that would change like every
three or four months oh okay so
previously it was oh you're the guy that
interviews Posh people and then I ran
for London mayor he was like oh you're
the guy that ran for London mayor and
it it has I've realized it's it's
important that I think you you change
what that thing that people are
referring to you as not as frequently as
possible but it just showcases that
you're still in people's Consciousness I
mean then there's a whole kind of deeper
conversation about like relevancy and
how important is relevancy and yeah that
was what I was going to ask you about
yeah yeah
um but so for me it was just I kind of
did more and more things and was going
slightly
they were kind of getting slightly
closer to the bone in terms of like
their feasibility or or how difficult
they were or like for example running
for London mayor yeah what was the deal
with that like the BBC released a list
of the candidates they thought they were
going to run
and at the bottom it said what you need
to do in order to run and I S and that
included and only needed two things a
ten thousand pound deposit that you got
back if you got five percent of the vote
which for context only three parties got
back almost every single election so
labor conservative and the lib damned no
the greens I think I don't think the lib
Dem get back there so like it's
incredibly difficult to get your deposit
back so you just need a ten thousand
pound deposit and to get
two signatures from each borough of
registered voters okay so you go to all
that's 66 signatures so that's all you
need and I remember I put it into a mate
group chat and one of my friends just
went you went run for London mayor
I'm sorry maybe I could maybe maybe I
could do this and then so I then
realized the feasibility of this thing
it was possible
I applied I I gave my I had enough just
enough money I thought if I make six or
seven videos out of this I'll probably
make my money back
um so I applied and then I realized oh I
need a story here I need something that
is entertaining because it's not going
to be funny for the six weeks or seven
weeks of the campaign if you're just
just the YouTuber that's running for
London mayor
um and then I was given the gift of
Lawrence Fox
um who was another candidate who was
running who was also went to the same
school as me not the same time
um but he had never no experience in
politics but he had five million pounds
in backing oh and
um I just thought amazing what happens
if you just have two two Posh boys who
have known like no history of politics
if they just run against each other and
now he was running on a on a quite a
controversial ticket
um of one of like um he was kind of
going for a relatively like a right wing
uh left a leaning kind of thing and I
just thought what what was interesting
is that I then had an opportunity he was
someone he was an easy person to to to
to make content about yeah because he
was very polemic he was very kind of in
the media a lot for doing crazy things
or saying silly things and so I thought
okay if I run against him it will be
there what do you mean by run against
him I just needed he needed a baddie I
needed a baddie in the story okay
um and so it was just kind of like an
opportunity to to do that and so that's
what I did I I challenged into him to
debates and like for him it wasn't a
good look that I was constantly cropping
up because he was like running on like a
serious ticket my number one
um my number one policy point was don't
vote for me
um and I was because I wanted to engage
I also wanted to engage young people to
vote like did not generally not for me
but for anybody yeah um because I think
we we hit we had a lot of like
politicians saying it's very important
to vote guys always use your vote but
normally if you're a young person like
this that so I don't care what you've
got to say um and so just having a horse
in the race hopefully was going to
Galvanize more young people to vote
um and not from but not for me and I
release my Manifesto which included like
things like we have many parks in London
but no Jurassic Parks I'm gonna change
that
um I wanted to carpet the M25 to make it
the smoothest Road in the world
um so like I just came up with I sat
down with some mates like in the pub
just to write my Manifesto and I made
like a six seven part uh series about
that what was really funny at one point
is that Lawrence Fox
um his campaign team obviously paying
for YouTube advertising and the YouTube
algorithm was just putting his YouTube
advertising in front of my videos so
therefore he was inadversely paying for
my campaign yeah so I then did a video
where I said Thank you to him and his
top donor by dressing up in a delivery
outfit buying a column of caterpillar
and delivering a cake and a card to
their offices and like essentially
breaking in a percentage of his delivery
driver and it just kind of like stirred
this pot
um of of
the political world I guess I wasn't
doing anything particularly Grand or or
but it's just fun what was your
this is going to sound somewhat
pretentious but what was your creative
process in making these seven videos
what are you looking out for how do you
how do you come up with the ideas
yeah so I realized quite quickly so
I don't think I've ever said this
publicly but um
I was always I always had a knack of
finding out where Lawrence Fox was
I know there's a reason for this
um so initially uh I got told by a
friend of mine who's a journalist that
he was going to be doing in this big
unveiling of a bus
um to launch his campaign and so then I
thought okay he's doing this big launch
of a bus what could I do okay for
political buses have got kind of a
history in our in our political
discourse why don't I wrap my car in the
words don't believe everything you read
on a bus and just tail him as he drives
through London on his open top bus and
so I did this the first time around and
it was it was quite funny and um he
Laurence Fox was a bit annoyed at me but
I found out who where he was because a
friend of mine was a journalist and then
it was very clear that his party that he
was running I think called the reclaimed
party they were then only sending press
releases to favorable media Outlets that
they trusted and they knew and but I
still managed to find out where he was
every single time because there was
there may or may not have been a mole
who was working in his party who didn't
enjoy working in his party so I thought
right let's just send Max the location
of the information and just do what you
like and so
um it was the creative process was
generally just trying to take advantage
of of opportunities that I saw and so
then I saw that he was he was getting
very upset Lawrence was going to be very
upset that Sadiq Khan wouldn't debate
him because he said we're both canvas in
this race
like debate means that he can't and said
he can't said no I'm only debating
proper candidates yep so Lawrence got
very upset that's ridiculous you need to
debate me so I then said well right
Lawrence we need to have a debate we're
both candidates at that point we were
both polling one percent in the polls so
it's like Lawrence we need to have a
debate come on let's do a debate and I
got him on the phone to say yes let's
have a debate and then he didn't turn up
to the debate oh I I hosted it outside
of his uh his office to make it as easy
for him and so I was just seeing I was
just watching what the mainstream
political kind of juggernauts were doing
against each other and then just kind of
doing the same thing with Lawrenceville
and so were you releasing a video sort
of each week of the campaign I was
trying to make them every week but it
was quite difficult to to come up with
um weekly uh weekly things about
Lawrence and then a lot of the time it
was just about the what it's like
running for a political position in this
country and so I had a great time where
the BBC and all the major
um broadcasters they they their
political ads are called every single
candidate of course that do the due
diligence and talk to them when we're
speaking to the head of BBC London the
political journalist had Lucy London she
said so why do you think you'd make a
good London mayor and I said I wouldn't
and it completely flawed and that she
was like well then why like why are you
running it's like I want to get more
young people to vote and she she
couldn't like I could I could tell that
it wasn't her favorite interview that
she'd done that day
um because I was just being quite
irritating to interview so a lot of the
the a lot of the process was just kind
of like talking to people and and
documenting that process and so to take
the example of the driving behind the
bus we don't believe everything you read
on bus yeah uh how does that then turn
into a YouTube video what is what is the
process of doing a thing and then
turning it into a video that does really
well look like so I think that it's it's
it's all it's all story
um it's you've got to have like set out
your why at the very beginning
um then you've got to set out the I
think my audience really enjoys the the
feeling that they're doing this whole
thing with me yeah so I can show the
process of how I'm actually making the
video in the video so I think once I I
normally start with the big ending so
like get the footage of me going behind
the bus and me talking to Lawrence Fox
and him getting annoyed and his his
security team trying to they tried at
one point I was reversing and they tried
to stand in front of my car like at the
back of my car to stop me from reversing
I just like gently nudged them further
and further back
um so I got that footage and then it's
then it's like okay I put that in the
timeline I said right I need the intro
or the hook the hook I call the hook or
the exposition hook then the exposition
what's the next position exhibition
explaining a little bit more about why
you're doing it
um how you're going to do it
um and then it's normally the thing and
I just kind of yeah it normally takes
about three or four days to edit a video
if I know exactly
what the beats are
um so normally the hook is is a is a
flashy 30 second like best bits
then it's me we call it the kitchen shot
so um I sit in my kitchen with my tripod
and like so I need to do this today and
this is going to involve doing this this
and this and then it's like that process
and so you're you're sort of Faking the
footage as if you were doing it at the
time or some of it is like presumably
when you wrap the car you might as well
film that process yeah yeah so yeah the
I'm filming that yeah I'm filming that
the wrapping the process the wrapping of
the car but um all of the not all of
about 50 of the time when like I'm in
the kitchen yeah talking to camera about
half of it is the time when I was
actually like thinking about it and I
just rolled okay but often there are
extra bits that I didn't explain well
enough when I did it originally that I
need to add yeah
um to get a little bit more uh Clarity
in what I'm trying to say
um so yeah it's just something to taking
people through this process and at the
end of it you get a video yeah
um are you how are you thinking about
like titles and thumbnails and all that
jazz at that point I wasn't at that
point I was classically doing the
classic like okay I uploading 15 minutes
let's make a thumbnail okay done
um that has changed a lot recently
um since I've kind of built out a team
and by a team I said one person yeah
um this is me and and my kind of
producer editor Aziz who he's just an
extra me basically so we work on the
video together we actually a lot of the
time we end we we start watch we make
the video at different ends and meet in
the middle so um and then we start the
end he starts at the beginning we'll
just we'll just meet the middle
um now we're super super driven on like
titles and thumbnails and understanding
what works and I I very luckily am part
of a Discord group of creators that
every Thursday we meet and we have an
hour and a half where we can talk each
brings like a topic to discuss and that
can be whether like roasting thumbnails
or roasting titles or content ideas and
it's got me much better at understanding
how YouTube works and understanding that
you the algorithm is just people and
that's I find really fast that changed
my perspective massively when someone
says oh the algorithm hates me or the
video's been killed by the algorithm
it's like no it's been killed because
people aren't watching or people don't
want to watch it to the end so you're
just like oh this is not one for the
audience is going to gonna it's gonna
like
um and so yeah if we want to get very
nerdy and talk about like CTR and avd
and things like that then I do you think
about that a lot and I'm editing a lot
of the time to music so I'll put I use
classical music as kind of exclusive my
USP and classical music is fantastic
because it has a beginning middle and
end in the pieces so if it's like a
three so let's say a 10 minute video
there's four
two and a half minute sections where I
find pieces of music and they will come
to their own natural Crescendo and then
we'll go to black screen and let's start
the next chapter so we're thinking a lot
of like okay let's keep the let's hold
the hand of the viewer all the way
through this and try and tell the best
story so covid happens you've got and
then you get this Zack and J Fashion
Week thing now you've got your 80 000
subscribers what was the growth of the
channel like and what were the sort of
main things that really made things take
off so I I went from so I got 80 000
subscribers in March 2019 and until
November 2021 so that is two and a half
two years two yeah I went from 80 000
subscribers to 400 000 subscribers
around two and a half years
and in November 2021 I hired disease and
from November 2021 to now which we are
in September 2022 so 10 months we're on
1.4 million
so a lot of exponential growth yeah so
it suddenly just went boom and that's
because I think I had just genuinely
somebody to talk to and somebody to just
is this a good idea
um someone to edit the videos with just
generally just sharing the successes and
the failures with somebody else with so
much like more enjoyable than
um like anything I'd done previously
yeah and it showcased in the in the like
in my social blades if you don't know
what socialblade is you can check your
numbers although your audience will
definitely know what social blade is um
you could see like them it's just like a
massive Spike almost like two weeks
after I hire disease and
so that made me realize okay I can I can
make this thing that I'm doing but with
a with a team not necessarily a massive
team but like two or three people I'm
really interested in the idea of just
having a small team
um who can just help me create these
these videos yeah I think it was it was
exactly the same for me so I first um
got an editor uh question who was our
first I guess employee
um about two and a half years into my
YouTube Journey so like late 2019 and
there was an immediate spike in
everything on the channel because now
all of a sudden I didn't have to do the
editing which meant I could spend more
time making videos and we'd release
courses and revenues cut rocket and then
we were able to build more of a team
around it
um I think that's like when you get to
that point where you can then start
working with someone even if it's a
part-time thing even if you're just sort
of Outsourcing a bit of editing here and
there to a friend it's just completely
changes the game absolutely and I think
I'm I'm still very scared of hiring
someone else as well because I'm not
very good with like committing to be
like okay this is a good idea even with
like Aziz not necessarily it was about
disease but I I was trying to find an
editor for like nine months because like
this person needs to be like absolutely
perfect they need to be another version
of me and know exactly my thought
process and there is that just comes by
working together over a long periods of
time
um and so I am I've got someone who's
starting in two weeks time to to help
make videos for China I do but I've got
a lot of I've got a um a platform on
China that does quite well
um an audience over there which is which
is cool
um and so it's just kind of building a
team and working together so how how
would you how do you make money these
days I make money from uh so ad Revenue
which
um it like since November 2021 in the
video really well
um ad Revenue kind of changes quite a
lot but that's kind of like 10 to 20
grand a month
um and but that almost all goes into my
wage aziz's wage the the and and also
just the cost of the videos like as
we're doing more and more
um the videos are just getting really
expensive
um like this I'm doing there's currently
a treasure hunt on to find a hundred
thousand dollar fish that was not that
was not cheap as you can imagine
um so and then the other comes from
Brand deals
um as well and that rate changes and
fluctuates as the videos do better
because they look at your kind of
average the last five videos
and then I do stand up as well so I've
just done I did a tour last year
stand-up tour just been to the Edinburgh
Fringe for a month I'm doing the London
Palladium in November um with my
stand-up show and oh yeah have you got
spectacles for that yes we still were
about two 200 tickets left oh amazing
please come on we should do a team trip
yes please do they'll be sick yeah let's
do that they'll be fun please do come
down
um and that's like that the stand up um
isn't something that that makes a huge
amount of money something that I found
really interestingly whilst actually
doing it because there are so many
people that are taking like slices of
the pie
um so yeah mainly it comes from just
brand deals and and AD Revenue um but I
am I'm now looking more to diversify by
watching a lot of your stuff actually
like again this needs to although my my
whole Niche is the silly guy doing silly
things that doesn't mean that I can't
also make
um a business and so hence the silly
company has been born it's called the
city company I love it good it's like
the boring company yeah exactly
um one thing I often worry about is what
does my career look like when I'm 40 or
50 am I still going to be a YouTuber
giving productivity advice yeah
I imagine if I were you I'd be even more
right yeah what is that like for you I'm
not even worried about 45 I'm worried
about the next six months and I think
that and this is why I ventured into
different areas like stand up is because
I want to be the most valuable
Entertainer that I can be so I want to
have a lot of strings to my bow with
YouTube essentially YouTube is what I do
now it's just storytelling and that I
think will be
um I think that's very valuable
regardless what platform you're on
um the best movies best TV shows best
YouTubers are purely just being able to
tell a story really really well
um so I think that I've got I've got
value in in there
um stand up as well being able to kind
of talk to people on large stage and in
front of lots of people I think is a
skill that I have so I don't know
whether I'll be making YouTube videos
and I don't know whether it's going to
be large pranky stuntsy stunty vids
um and but I hope that I will have some
value within the entertainment world
because of the experience I have with
just telling stories and I guess so is
your model that as long as you can make
a living doing the thing that you love
which is entertaining people then you're
happy you you aren't chasing big Revenue
numbers and all that [ __ ] or no yes or
no like I think that I realized very
quickly when I hit a million subscribers
that chasing my like uh constantive
goals is a very dangerous game because
you've hit those numbers if you ever do
hit those numbers and you then do a big
sign they're like oh okay now what I
don't think I'm particularly money
orientated
um I I don't think that I'm like like
saving like collecting the pennies just
to make sure that I I hit a certain
Revenue number I think at the moment
it's just being able to do things that I
didn't people don't think are possible
so I've got a few mad mad video ideas
that I should be happy if I can make
them like I wanna I wanna water ski
behind a cruise ship
um and I was telling this I was telling
this to uh my my mechanic who was doing
my mot and like first of all it was like
blue is mine like the idea that you
could be a YouTuber but um he was like
oh my God that sounds amazing oh yes but
awesome and then there was a woman who
was also getting her car service when I
told him about the idea to get a water
ski behind a cruise ship she was weirdly
also called Karen and she said oh you'll
never do that no that's you can't do
that and just just this random woman
telling me I can't do this because maybe
like I will do this for the next five
I'm Garrett I'm sure I'm gonna be able
to water ski behind a cruise ship
um so I think for me at the moment it's
just being able to
I don't do you know what Ali I was
listening to truthfully I was listening
to your um episode with KPM keep mockers
yeah and before I got here and you kind
of you asked the same question and I
remember thinking on the tube I don't
know what the answer is to that question
I generally don't know whether I'm doing
this for monetary value whether I'm
doing this for kind of quote-unquote
fame or Acclaim
um and I also don't know whether I'm
making this is probably quite a a
detrimental thing to be thinking about
but I don't know whether when I'm making
a video that I know is going to do
really well or like is a big vid I don't
know whether I'm excited because I'm
really excited to make this video or I'm
excited because I know it's going to do
really well I still haven't come to
terms with which one is is is winning in
that kind of Angel versus devil on my
shoulder oh wait so I was having a chat
to a YouTuber who I met over the weekend
who has like 20 million subscribers and
I asked this question of like how do you
balance a kind of
education value of the video with the
money with this with growth and he was
like it changes depending on the day of
the week and I was like oh that's
reassuring because I definitely have
that and even a guy with 20 million
subscribers he was like yeah this is uh
it depends how I'm feeling depends on if
I've had enough sleep depends on like
sometimes I'm very Money Motivated
sometimes very status motivated
sometimes I just really want to make a
really good video and that it changes
every day and oh that was so refreshing
that is refreshing actually because I
was just like I I feel like they're
surely there must be an answer to this
and everyone I've asked is always like I
mean Mark has this thing was very much
like I just want to make a really good
video yeah I was like that sounds simple
enough I feel like my own motivations
are a bit more dodgy where it's like to
what extent do I want to be a
inspirational teacher to people because
I want the status versus because I
actually think it's a absolutely all of
those things yeah I always I always
quite I find it quite hard to to
comprehend that people like when Marco
says that that there are people who
actually are that kind of like
vindicating their own in their own
self-belief that that is all that
they're making the videos for us because
they just want to make a good video yeah
I do sometimes go I like going back and
watching videos of mine from like two
years ago of like experiences that I've
had be like oh that was that was a
really fun time or I enjoyed that's that
was a fun video I liked watching that
video
um and so I find myself sometimes creepy
into it into a world of like I'm making
this video because I know it's going to
do really really well and how do you
feel about the the process when so I I
generally find when I'm chasing numbers
it feels bad and I yes don't have very
easily yes yeah yes and how have you
stopped chasing numbers Ali I do
journaling sessions basically every
month where I'm just like right where I
have to reaffirm to myself that chasing
numbers is not the thing that I actually
want to do because it's just so easy
like you see the numbers just there and
just like oh [ __ ] hey this was an 8 out
of 10 video damn view to subscriber
ratio is going down God like Max's
videos are doing really well I guess
theory is doing real and it's just the
whole comparison trap and and then it's
like okay no hang on let's take a step
back do a lot of journaling write five
pages about why I'm doing this thing and
why this is good and why I don't need to
worry about money and all this kind of
stuff yeah no I'm Linda the conclusion
of make videos you want to make don't
make videos to chase numbers no
absolutely and I think I'm now as of
recording this podcast right now I'm
probably in a bit of a vulnerable
position because I've just done stand up
for six weeks and I haven't posted on
the channel for six weeks and so I've
seen things are starting to dip again
and I'm now like oh no uh this is the
moment where it all goes bad and I post
a video that people don't like when I'm
doing just for the sake of posting a
video because I think it's going to do
really really well
um what I do really what I have learned
that is really kind of refreshing is
that the more that I make
like fun videos or videos that I enjoy
the more fun video ideas that I get in
my mind and the more I make them so it's
kind of like this this positive cycle
and this negative cycle yeah so I don't
I I haven't been able I don't have those
processes I think in place because I
think I'm probably arrogant enough for
27 and not even that's fine when when I
have kind of like a really low week then
I'll just get through it'll be I'll get
out the other side and it'll be fine but
that's probably a quite a quite a bad
kind of thought process to be going to I
do I do I do therapy yeah which is one
of the first things that I bought with
some YouTube money was like therapy it
is very useful but then it all boils
down to like ideas of like self-esteem
yep and that is much
harder because you can talk about that
and I know I'm like the coach I know all
of the processes I'm now going to
therapy knowing exactly the questions
that my therapist is going to ask me I
know the same response I'm going to get
I mean I know the bit where he's going
to get me to cry and then I tell him off
because I'm like you're just doing that
because you want me to cry
um so I've kind of got to kind of a an
impasse where I know the processes I
know the things that make me feel bad
when it comes to like negative thoughts
when it comes to video making because
it's all about self-esteem and like what
other things
just wanting to be like liked I think
and wanting to be like have videos that
do really well and like have big numbers
and but the goal posts just move daily
like I looked at my um we looked at Aziz
and I looked at our goals that we set at
the beginning of 2022 and that's to hit
800 000 subscribers we were on 500 000
at that point and we're now 1.4 million
and we haven't taken a step back why I
haven't taken a step back to think like
okay it's fine we've more than double
tripled our goal for this year I'm not
thinking can we hit two minute by the
end of the year
uh you're those those noise alleys is
you you're realizing like this guy needs
this guy needs some help no I'm honestly
I'm thinking mate I know the feeling
like I'm thinking that like it's so nice
hearing you speak about exactly the same
thoughts that go through my mind
um I think I have been very uh careful
slash like to to try my very best not to
set any kind of quantitative goal uh at
least not a goal that's outside of my
control so I might have a goal of like
one one or two videos a week because
that's in my control but the anything
around like a subscriber account view
account I found whenever I have a goal
like that it is a net negative for me
and so how do I control the things I can
control and only set goals that are like
that
to which someone might be like oh but
that's not ambitious if you set a big
hairy audacious goal then you're more
likely to hit it and I'm like yeah
probably
go back the conversation with Marquez
you talked about like chasing every
every year he wants to go like hit his
goals hard or chase his goals
that how do you feel about that kind of
that idea of like it's a very goal
orientating goal driven because when you
reach goals I was talking to a YouTuber
whose goal was to hit 10 million
subscribers
and he did it and his growth was
enormous he was like okay now what I've
done it fantastic yeah I don't I don't I
don't feel particularly different I
don't feel fantastic and there's there's
flat hedonic adaptation that I get I'm
really interested in because now it just
looks like two YouTubers that people
watch just kind of like not complaining
about yeah God is it so hard
1.4 million instead of 800 oh God and so
then then I catch myself in like okay
don't be don't be such an ungrateful
idiot yeah and about the whole thing
um so it's it's constantly trying to
kind of so just on that on that note uh
Darren Brown's book happy is really good
um it's stoicism and happiness and stuff
in it he talks about the uh kind of
conundrum of being a celebrity in that
there are all sorts of negatives
associated with it but you're never
allowed to talk about it because you
have to be just grateful oh my God like
thank you so much to the fans all of all
of that stuff and the instant like in a
public forum you talk about the negative
suddenly the public turns against you
because it's like of course you've ended
up in this privileged position Etc
um so I appreciate you actually yeah
it's going to be a problem yeah the way
that I've I sort of think about it is
um I ask myself the question of like
you know if I if I had 100 million in
the bank how would I be spending my time
and the answer is I'd be making videos
about cool [ __ ] that I've learned so I
can teach it to other people and
document the process and I'm like cool
do I need 100 million in the back to do
that no I could just do that yeah I'm
like why don't I just do that I'm like
oh well I want numbers to go up I want
to be more liked I want to get more
accolades
but it's like there was another really
great from uh Alex formosi actually one
of the jacked guys I was telling you
about
he he had a really good quote he said
that
um he realized that when he was 20 he
wanted to be a millionaire yeah but when
he was a millionaire he wanted to be 20.
and so why is he wasting all this time
like grinding and not enjoying the
process when we he's just want to go
back well we're going to want to go back
to the start when he gets to the
destination and so I I do genuinely
think about that a lot and I think I
wrote it in my like Journal yesterday or
something
um just this idea of just making sure
that whatever I'm doing I am taking the
time to enjoy the process and not being
too goal-oriented because I think being
too goal oriented in a way takes your
eye off of the actual process yes I
think just whilst you're talking about I
think my one if I'm being totally
truthful it is all Accolade driven I
think at the moment is that's that's
what I want I want to be able to say
that I've done XYZ but I don't know who
I'm like want to say it to when there
was a I did my tour sign up tour
um someone said oh what do you want to
do now I said I want to do the London
Palladium because that as a venue is one
that I used to grow out watching like
Jack D and and uh people like comedians
like that doing their specials at the
London Palladium and so much so that
I've rather kind of uh arrogantly is
that the word um I I have asked the
London Palladium who the youngest person
who's ever done their own stand-up
special at the London Palladium and I'm
waiting to hear back because there's
something in me that wants me to be the
youngest person ever to have done it
which is a really like it's a really
toxic way of thinking about things I
think
um but I think I am all still very much
Accolade driven at the moment
um which I don't know whether that's a
positive or A negative thing but I think
at the moment that's just how I am so
there's uh there's a book I'm reading at
the moment called the second Mountain
okay I'd have called A Child Called
David Brooks um it's thesis is basically
that in life there are two mountains the
first mountain is the mountain of
success and status and happiness and
being Accolade driven and all that kind
of stuff and usually we're on that model
When We're Young that that mountain and
then one of three things happens either
you get to the summit and you realize
hang on as I said or you get uh knocked
off the mountain because someone dies
and you're like [ __ ] or you get knocked
off the mountain because of a health
problem and you're like oh my God like I
have a second chance at life and in each
of those three situations you realize
there is a second mountain and that's
the second Mountain which is more about
service it's more about Joy instead of
it being like hey I want to be cool and
have freedom and stuff which is very
much what I optimized for the first
Mountain that's more about I want to
commit myself to a cause I want to
really invest in relationships I want to
invest in like a local community I want
to have a family and that is where you
experience true joy as a second Mountain
whereas the first mountain is more about
like that short-term Hedonism and Status
games that we all play
um do you think that's it do you think
that's an age an age-based Mountain yeah
I think hiking situation there seems to
definitely like from from people I know
who have had lots of success in life
definitely as they've gone older
especially as they've had kids it's like
an immediate thing that takes them onto
the second Mountain
um but what what I guess I was I was I
was trying to get from the book and is
like he he talks about
if you if you recognize yourself as
being on the first Mountain which I do
how do you then recognize that and
actually shift to the second Mountain
knowing that like the pursuit of status
and accolades and stuff
is hollow and empty at the end of the
day and just like basically everyone
who's done it says it it says that
that's true and so it's like oh what I'm
trying to do is figure out okay how can
I short circuit my desire for status and
accolades and stuff and just move to
Second Mountain mode sooner rather than
later so that I feel less kind of
anxious around am I going to be relevant
five years from now or is my YouTube
Channel Growing fast enough
um
there is a great I mean a slight tangent
um
I think Colin and Samir told the story
of the Z of Aziz Ansari meeting Frank
Ocean at an awards ceremony and the
season sorry went to Frank Ocean was
like man how'd you do it like you just
come along you just make awesome albums
and then you dip for like five years and
we don't hear from you and then you just
come up and make another Banger out but
how do you do it and Frank Ocean just
said I just make less money
um and this is like oh my God that's
that's that's so true like you're just
you're doing it because you're not
turning around and saying yes to a huge
check that's that's coming from from
somebody else and that really resonated
that that still really resonates with me
it's like it actually that is is true
like how do you become somebody that is
very enviable from everybody else or you
just make less money than everyone else
there's a there's a book called finite
and infinite games
um which is big in the sort of business
Tech Pro scene um but basically the it
starts off with the idea that there are
some games that are finite games that
have an ending and there are some games
that are infinite games where the object
or where the objective is to continue
playing the game so something like
Minecraft is an infinite game there's no
real Point score like you just play
because of dance like you build a Lego
thing because it's fun but something
like fortnite is a very fine art game
where there's a scoreboard and you have
to win win at the end of the thing yeah
and
it's kind of got me thinking that like
in life there are finite games a game in
the uh the game of I want to get the
million subscriber plaque is a finite
game like there is an ending but the
infinite game of like I'm doing the
thing I love and making a living doing
it that that's the sort of thing that we
both want to just actually be able to
continue doing and so if you're at the
point where you genuinely are playing
your infinite game which is you get to
do the thing you love and and you get to
make a living doing it
the only goal that makes them that it
then therefore makes sense to have is
the goal of being able to continue doing
the thing
and so the way I think about this is
that like if my goals are like revenue
or like more big numbers and stuff like
I'm already doing the thing I'm already
like doing what I love and making money
from it so why don't I set my goals to
be like how do I make sure this is
sustainable over a 30-year time Horizon
rather than potentially neglecting
actually making decent content for the
sake of over monetizing for the sake of
a course or for the sake of a brand deal
or a short short-term money decisions
tend to be finite gaming yeah I found
and and whereas the more I'm actually
doing the thing I love in producing
content I'm proud of and don't really
care about the money tends to be more
infinite gaming there's the idea that as
soon like people often find that let's
say people have hobbies as soon as they
start being paid for to do their Hobbies
they start to not enjoy it yeah where do
you stand on on that if your whole idea
is to make videos and enjoy making
things that's a really good question the
way I the way I square that is by
thinking and I have this literally as
like an affirmation that I've written in
my bullet Journal because I was doubling
with that the other day what does it say
let me see if I can get it like word for
word
um
I don't care about numbers I just do my
thing and my amazing team takes care of
the rest
so it's like in my dream world the only
thing I'd be thinking about is how do I
make how do I learn cool things and
teach this to people and the fact that I
now have a team means that they can
worry about the monetization
and so I'm thinking that if I can just
separate these two things out like the
creative from the commercial then and
actually a lot of companies have a
creative arm and a commercial arm
because those two things don't really
work nicely together and if I can do
that in my life then that's that's a
dream okay I need to I need to can I
have your team please
yes fantastic
calls with other creative friends and
stuff to talk talk through the process
of how we're trying to get there um one
of the things I have in my bucket list
is stand-up comedy set ah yes what is
what's the deal with stand-up comedy how
does one get started if one is into
interested in the thing that sounds like
that's not at the beginning of a
standout so what's the deal with
stand-up comedy
um good job good job it's very matter I
don't know how the pubs and clubs will
enjoy that
um stand-up comedy is uh an incredibly
rewarding experience but it's also one
of the most terrifying experience you
can do and Rob Beckett the comedian uh
gave some incredible advice about how to
get started in stand-up comedy and he
said imagine you're starting a
nine-to-five job in an office you go in
on a Monday on your first day and by
Friday you kind of know what you're
doing you kind of know who the people
are you know what your job is
startup comedy is exactly the same thing
but you're just going to work five
minutes at a time
so it takes so much longer to be
comfortable on stage to know what you're
doing to know where where your strengths
and where your weaknesses are and I
generally think that I genuinely think
that was stand-up comedy it is a it is a
case of just doing it and it is a it is
a world where it's the most you have to
do it on the job job that you can
possibly do I don't think you can do
much planning or you can write jokes but
like jokes that you write in your room
will genuinely I found will have the
opposite effect on stage Josie don't
think a funny will be really funny on
stage and jokes you think are really
good are rubbish on stage yeah
um and I was very lucky that I had a a
ready-made audience who who were kind of
happy to be kind of guinea pigs for me
for like six months I was just doing
loads of work in progress shows
um for in front of like 30 people I then
very luckily found a great team again
um of producers and directors a director
who works with Joe lysitt on all of his
stuff
as well as having done the Dan and Phil
World Tour like five or six years ago
and so when I said I want to make an
hour-long show he came on board and we
wrote this show essentially together and
he really supported me on that
um and he's absolutely amazing because
he understands YouTube he understands
what I was good at once understands what
my audience wants when they come to a
live show but also merges that with
stand up and the way that the
traditional comedy World Works um so if
you're going to do it I think
just go to an open mic night where no
one knows who you are and do five
minutes and just stand on stage it will
be bad like and that's okay yeah
um people might not laugh but as long as
you've got that first one out the way
early doors then I think it's all okay
and and then someone also said to me
people when they go to Comedy they want
to feel like that they're being taken
care of by the person on stage so being
a good stand-up comedian is just being
able to be on stage and seem totally
relaxed and everybody else seeing
feeling totally relaxed because they're
like oh okay this guy or gown knows what
they're doing that's fine we can just
enjoy the jokes whereas if you come on
stage and almost immediately someone
picks up the mic and they
are messing around with the cable
the audience is immediately like oh god
um I really hope this is okay uh and
then as soon as you do the audience in
that position you've lost like that they
have already not turned against you but
they're not in a position where they're
gonna be comfortable enough to laugh
so Ali the answer is do it just just go
and do it and don't worry about how well
it goes because it will go badly and
when it goes badly it's a great story
yeah it's either a good time or it's a
good story yeah
absolutely can we do a YouTube collab
where you where we I do a stand-up
thingy and you're like my sure supporter
yeah or something yeah no absolutely
that'd be super fun yeah and then part
of the story can be this conversation
we've just had online I've been
interested in the standard comedy for a
while and then you came with a podcast
six months ago we had this conversation
and I was like Ali you've just got to do
it yeah yeah it's like act two or
whatever however you do storytelling
content which I've never done before but
we'll give it a go um that that could be
fun how how does one become funny
that's a very good question
um
comedy I think there's a there's a real
structure to Comedy
um so
comedy is basic comedy is specificity
so
um your your so I had a joke where I
would go through my own notes on my
phone
and I found that
um on my phone I'd written on Christmas
day six years ago weirdly uh girls
allowed to jump the song Jump by Girls
Aloud I just written on a note I have no
idea why I'd written it so I've had a
bit in my show about
um when we write weird notes on our
phones and I just I realized when I was
writing that um
the joke initially was something like
um I wrote this and my family had asked
me with putting together a Christmas
playlist and there it goes landro my
director said no make it really specific
said
Uncle John tasked me with tasked me with
put together a Christmas playlist and so
I chose girls love jump so that's much
more that's much funnier whereas the
concept of it isn't inherently that
funny but the specificity of Uncle John
makes it funnier so comedy a specificity
I've found
um and I think that it's it's just I I
don't really know um we think a lot
about um it's also contradictions so
this is what we're thinking when Aziz
and I think about like titles YouTube
titles and Concepts it's taking
something that everybody knows and doing
the weirdest thing with it so I got
roadkill what's with weirdest thing you
can do to roadkill serve it to Michelin
star chefs as is there any other any
other concept that I did video ideas
we've had this like really contradictory
we're the richest man in the world for
seven minutes and that was a great
example of how like the original number
one idea was around for a long time and
basically making the video but then just
adding that for seven minutes and trying
to work that into the video walk by
without being
um made because it just makes it way
more intriguing because I began good to
know the world people think kind of like
well it's probably not going to be real
or like some joke thing but for seven
minutes it's like okay so what lootball
do we find here why only seven minutes
oh yeah I mean like oh yeah and the
other one was I caught fish and chips
uh from the world's most polluted river
so I8 fish and chips from the Thames so
that's a lot of like the comedy of the
channel comes from just contradiction so
we're just constantly looking at like
okay cameras what's the weirdest thing
you could do with the camera uh could
you make a camera out of like a potato
or um and I think that's just just
that's just content in general I think
on YouTube it's like a lot of the time I
look at my homepage and I realize oh
it's just it's kind of contradictions
oh yeah so we did a video with adult
actors
um uh porn stars if you will and we got
them to just act in a short film so I I
hired porn stars to act in my short film
and so like that was because and it was
great they were they were great actors
and and we had a great time and it was
it was a fun video to shoot that how do
you hire a porn star that was hard that
genuinely that was the hardest part of
that video was trying to just trying to
get in contact with like porn agents
because I don't know any uh none of my
not my current days
um and so I the best way was was
generally was Instagram shout outs
that's why I find a lot of like my
videos happen because someone on
Instagram knows someone so it was it was
a difficult day when I was like hi does
anyone know any porn stars genuinely
just like for a for a video not that
kind of video but does anyone know any
porn stars and we got yeah uh some some
really really cool people who came down
and and were great actors yeah I think
the the specificity point is really like
our the thinking back to the start of
our conversation when you did your uh
impromptu bit about Greg and like the
accent and the the catch-ups yeah the
front it's just the the the the
specificity is what makes that story
like really funny yeah if you just
talked about a guy coming in he'd
spilled something on his on his shirt
that's not funny but it's Yeah the more
specific I think often is the funnier
what about accents what about them so I
another thing I have in my bucket list
is learn how to do acts of cool accents
okay and it's a thing that so my my
singing teacher is like a professional
Broadway actor or stuff and has actually
studied accents and I can do like 50 of
them with like actual
like notation and [ __ ]
um you've busted out like four or five
so far like is that just a thing that
came naturally to you how do you how do
you go about yeah Impressions and stuff
accents I can't give much more kind of
insight other than just like I've just
been doing them for a long long time and
just being like imitating people that
I've seen on the Telly ever since I was
a kid
um and I just yeah I really enjoy doing
accents and there are some I can do
something I can't do
um like something I can do well so I'm
gonna do really really badly what are
your top three favorite ones my favorite
one
South African I like doing
um I like doing what else do I like
doing I like doing really pop like
really Posh is really fun because I get
to in my in my kind of my life I have
met a lot of these they just you know
they just do their teeth just do not
touch at all the the they really just
chat like this and it's it's fantastic
absolutely fantastic wonderful to be
here with Ali
um what wonderful guy actually most much
watches content that just slightly goes
into Boris yeah fantastic
um so I you know I like South African I
like
um I like Posh
um and just American it's fun because
American is just like quite difficult to
do because you just very easily just go
into Southern and Texan which becomes a
stereotype but I I've just been doing
them my whole life really nice
um how does stand up compare to the like
doing stuff on on video like is it very
different completely different yeah yeah
it's completely different because it's
you get that immediate feedback
number one but also the kind of con the
way you present the content has to be
completely different so I've tried in
the past like putting on like two or
three minute videos during my stand-up
set and it just feels like you're
putting my direct calls that you're
putting on videos for the kids so it's
like you're like you're in class you're
like and now here we're gonna watch this
uh this video so they've got to be
really short sharp and just almost
responding to whatever the joke was or
whatever you've just said on stage
um so it is very different you've got to
you're thinking much more about
the idea of liveness okay then you are
uh when you then you definitely don't
think about that with YouTube but comedy
is at its best when the audience feels
like it's the first time the comedian
has ever said that and so there are lots
of times when you have audience
interaction that's why all interactions
works so well is because the audience
feels like oh this comedian is being
really funny in the moment and is doing
something that hasn't been rehearsed and
hasn't been planned and there are there
are different tactics that you can use
that you can almost fake that or not
fake that will facilitate that feeling
um so there's some audience interaction
work that I do where I know there's only
a very finite number of answers in which
the question I'm asking the audience
member can give me back and so I've got
in the chamber three or four different
responses that I know work and know are
fun so that's an example
um oh God and put him on the spot here
um but I'm just trying to think back to
the show okay right yeah it's gonna
slightly ruin the fact if you come to
the uh the Palladium show but whatever
um there's a bit in the show where I try
and play a game of uh find a posh person
in the audience and I call it guess whom
um so what I do is I put ask everyone to
put their hands up in the air and I say
right keep your hands up in the air if
you've ever referred to your parents as
mummy or daddy right okay so you keep
everyone has their hands in the air some
people like drop their hands and then I
will pretend on stage that there are
more hands up on the the right then on
the left so I'll say oh there are
seemingly more Posh people on the right
than on the left
I know that a little bit like our
political climate and that feels very
live even though that's a joke that I
have written previously
um it always goes down really well
because as a joke it's not that funny
but it's just it feels like it's the
first time I've ever said it right so if
you come to the podium show keep your
mouth shut
um so yeah what's it like
working with a director to write and
produce like a whole like hour-long show
like what how's that presumably it's
very different to a five minute seven
minute routine yeah you are looking at
the flow of a show so you want to come
on stage and you want to be high energy
at the beginning you want to get into
things immediately so the audience feel
comfortable and they're like okay these
guys know what he's doing but then over
time you can't have you can't sustain
that energy the whole hour because your
audience gets exhausted
so you've got to give them periods where
they can relax and they can slightly
almost turn off a little bit from what
you're saying because I think the
difficulty with comedy with our long
comedy is you're listening to someone
talk for an hour which is an incredibly
difficult thing to do to concentrate for
an hour and if it's like a certain type
of comedian who are very very clever
comedy you've got to be on the whole
time as an audience membership to
realize okay this is going on so we do
have we we make the sections very clear
so the audience knows okay I'm in this
bit for seven minutes or five minutes I
can see the ending for this section that
helps a lot
um also giving time to put on put on a
TV a show for the kids like just like
having letting them have a reset where
they can watch something rather than
having to listen to me all the time so
it a lot of the time it's just form it
formatting and then it's just about
writing those individual elements and
and thinking about what works and what
doesn't but mainly it's about the
structure of a show and so a lot of the
time when we're doing previews we're
like swapping and changing it's like
we'll put that bit after this bit but
that needs a connecting bits yeah but
then that affects a callback that we've
got later on the show so it's it's very
bitty okay and what what are the
economics of being a stand-up comedian
right is it a reasonable path to make a
living for a normal person
I don't think it is no
um so you have got
you're gonna have your producer so these
are the various people that will take a
cut you've got producers what will take
12 and a half to twenty percent of uh
the show's takings you've got a agent
who will take 10 to 12 and a half
percent 10 to 15 of the takings
um so already you've lost about 25 of of
your earnings there the venue then takes
normally depends sometimes they do like
a flat fee but most the time it's like a
percentage so they're taking 30 to 40
percent
um so before you even turn the
microphone on you're losing 60 to like
costs
um and then you've got the costs of like
a director if you've if you've kind of
had the money to do that you've got PR
that will kind of like hopefully get
people to to go to your show I have just
done a month at the Edinburgh Fringe
Festival
um in a venue that's about 75 seats um
so it was a small venue and I chose it
to be a relatively small venue I sold
every seat out in in that venue over the
month and I think we which was great and
but because idea was that we wanted to
make it a real scarcity of the tickets
so we sold every ticket
um for the run which is about 2 000
tickets every 30 days and I think I took
home about two and a half thousand
pounds and oh well over over the month
and that like it spent we've spent like
six months writing the show
um and so I think I mean Fringe is is a
bad example because no one makes any
money at The Fringe anyway The Fringe
and that was one of the big issues this
year is because it's getting so
incredibly expensive and that it's so
difficult for any new wait what do you
mean it's getting expensive
accommodation is ludicrously expensive
it's kind of a thousand fifteen hundred
pounds to stay in Edinburgh for the
month in like a tiny box room
um just the whole creation process of
bringing your shirts The Fringe is so
expensive um so you're going to lose a
lot of money
um so my point is you don't really start
making lots of mountains like large
amounts of money until you're
consistently doing four 500 seat of
venues
for the year okay
um and I think that's that's going to be
a problem because going going forwards
um also the main the show that was
selling out the Edinburgh Fringe this
year were all because they had platforms
on social media
um all because they were really big on
Twitter or they had a video that went
viral recently or they were YouTube uh
YouTube audiences
um and I think for the comedy industry
that's something that's going to be
quite uh I would be relatively worried
if you're a comedian and you're not kind
of engaging in somewhat in the social
media side of things I can understand
why you wouldn't be because it's like
well hold on no I got into stand-up
comedy because I want to be a stand-up
comedian I don't what's this whole stuff
and now I need to be a content creator
and do like silly Tick Tock dances
there's a real misconception about what
it means to be a tick tock Creator or an
online Creator
um but yeah the big comedians in the UK
like obviously taking away your
gervaises and your your Joe license
they're probably making good money but
everybody else is is you I don't think
you're making huge definitely not making
generational uh money to kind of retire
off yeah yeah it's uh so I've got a
friend who is uh a musician and um we
just recently got a record deal a couple
years ago and he's just like oh my God
they keep on saying I have to go on Tick
Tock and do silly dances and he's just
like I got into this to make music and
now I'm having to build a social media
following because that's apparently
where songs go viral yes and stuff and
even in even in the book publishing
industry there's a time every every June
or July where the Publishers will start
emailing everyone who's got any kind of
audience because they know that the way
to guarantee Book Sales is to give a
book deal to someone with an audience
um and a lot of genuine writers are just
like I I don't have a platform I need to
build my email list I know I should be
on Twitter and Instagram and all those
things and I just can't be asked because
it's not what I signed up to do yeah and
so it's just weird weird incentives
where a lot of the social media famous
people are getting book deals and stuff
where now writing a book is now
anyone with any kind of audience can
just publish a book with a penguin or
something like that yeah uh whereas
before it used to be more of a Prestige
you've published some a book uh working
on it well first draft is done now we're
in the editing stage okay [ __ ] because
I'd be interested again to know what the
what the the financials of of that are
like because because I know with how it
goes you you get given in advance when
you sign the deal is that where most the
money comes from and then it doesn't
actually matter how many it sells or do
you get a percentage of how many it
sells yeah so you get an advance and
that's usually sort of let so
um most advances for first time time
authors maybe they'll give you like 10
grand in in the UK in the US it's more
like sort of in the tens of thousands
two hundreds of thousands if again if
you have an audience
um so let's say you get a 20 000 pound
Advance you'll get 25 of it like on
signing 25 of it when you hand in the
manuscript uh 25 of it when the
hardback's published and the other 25
when the paperback's published so across
a four year period you'll get this
twenty thousand pounds Over a four-year
period
um it's an advance which means you have
to pay it off uh and you paid off from
book royalties and so with the advance
they'll say that okay so it's a 20 000
pound advance and it will give you 7.5
of the royalties
um up until you sell X tens of thousands
of copies and then 10 then 12.5 and then
15 is like whoa that's really a high
royalty figure so if you sell a book for
15 quid the author will be making about
a quid from it ish if they're lucky and
for the first 20 000 of those that pays
off the advance and then you just take a
loan you're in debt you're in debt uh I
mean if you if the bug doesn't earn out
and it's uh earn out in its Advance
which the vast majority of books don't
then you don't pay anything because I
mean the publisher has taken that risk I
see and so once your book is earned out
it's Advanced at that point you're
making a pound every sale and if you're
a James clear and you've sold 12 million
copies now you're winning yeah if you're
basically everyone else and you've sold
like oh there was a stat that was going
right on Twitter because there was some
book fair recently where like 98 of
books don't and sell more than like 20
copies so like the publishing industry
is losing so much money but it's the
atomic habits it's the Harry Potter's
it's the these huge books that are
funding the whole thing for the other
the other minutes that don't make any
money at all yeah we we I did a video
where I I got a book to be number one on
Amazon bestseller in the Poetry section
yeah I watched that though and um it's
it's certainly Jaden my my like I saw
that I think it was Piers Morgan said
like to congratulate tweet for himself
that his book was the top of the Amazon
best-selling list and I just kind of saw
that thinking you need about 25 copies
to get to get up there
um but it's do you think that's
detrimental to the the publishing
industry in in the whole do you think
like the way that yeah I think the the
publishing industry from from people I
know who are in it are just like yeah it
gets kind of dying there's no need for
that gatekeeper anymore like back in the
day where the only way to get your ideas
out would be via television or via
publishing press these days anyone can
publish anything on Amazon and it's
trivial and so like what is the point of
a publisher they say they're gonna
they're gonna Market the book and stuff
but they don't really and they'd go
after people with audiences knowing the
audience is consultative yeah it's a
weird weird kind of kind of system
um where yeah the margins are so low uh
that so within I mean as probably I felt
very like uh like an like an alien
um when I was in Edinburgh Fringe
because I was somebody who had an
audience and I was selling tickets and
it was my first edible Fringe and I've
done comedy for 18 months and so all of
the the comedy kind of reviewers that
could that comedians comedians reviewers
came in I got absolutely slated like I
was getting horrific reviews
um and I do is that the same with in the
book world that people with with
audiences are kind of like their books
are like looked down on by traditional
yes very much big big publishing yeah so
there's a there's a lot of sort of
Insider baseball type stuff around the
New York Times bestseller list and how
if you are an academic uh then you don't
need to sell as many copies to get on
the best seller list as if you are a
YouTuber for example
screw that you know and you have to
really like sell loads of copies for
them to not not even be able to justify
not having you on the best similarly the
way they do it is like it's not it's
it's like this weird secret formula um
kind of which is closely guarded like
the Coca-Cola recipe of there are
certain Walmarts in random places of
America where they sample those to see
how many people in Texas in this random
Walmart in this random Town bought your
book in real life because the people
with online audiences drive everyone to
the Amazon pre-order page and so that's
an unfair advantage that people like you
and me would have if we were to write a
book but a normal author they would wait
the Walmart Texan sale way way higher
than the Amazon one and so there's all
this stuff around how do you actually
get on the bestseller list Beyond
actually selling books because that's
not really how it works but there's a
lot of random Factory around that with
similarly with music publishing there's
all sorts of stuff that is a bit weird
it sounds like comedy is similar yeah
it's I think it's almost exactly the
same and I was talking to a few people
who have been nominated for the award up
in Edinburgh and like that's that's the
one of the most probably the most
um coveted award in comedy or or thing
in comedy and a lot of those people on
that list are like oh I'm I'm probably
gonna have to quit comedy in the next
like year and a half because I just
can't afford to keep doing this it's
just two yeah it's too expensive
so what do you like I I guess coming
full circle to the career question that
we talked about at the start like would
you see your career as being over the
next like
months to years I really don't know I
think my my next goal is to to build
build a team and that's not necessarily
a huge team but a team that I'm really
proud of and really
like just I trust implicitly
um
and that's hard that's really hard to do
um I think I'd still like to be telling
stories I think I'd still like to be
entertaining people I still like to be
doing silly things because I think there
is a gap in the market for just doing
things that are inherently silly and fun
for the sake of it and that's one of my
biggest bug bears with TV I've had a few
kind of conversations with big producers
and I'll pitch them to my dears like
yeah we like it but but what's the why
why are you doing this why why what's a
deeper meaning here
and I often say just there isn't one
it's just because it's something that is
just inherently silly and fun it's like
now there needs to be a why here and so
I really like this I this this this USB
of like just doing something silly for
the sake of being silly as long as no
one's getting hurt and it's a bit fun I
think there is there is a place for that
so I'm I think I'm gonna try and kind of
Market myself as as the us as the as the
silly guy the silly guy the silly guy
Posh silly guy Posh silly guy yeah I
mean that's what we'll be said behind my
back
um but uh yeah I'm I'm the Potter silly
guy nice but I'd love to ask you about
um burnout
a lot of creators talk about kind of
burnout
um what's been your relationship with
both uh I have burnt out a few times
um I think during lockdown was a was it
was was a bad like it it showed it read
its ugly head physically like I felt I
was I was I was inherently just very
depressed and I don't think I do enough
to combat burnouts again it's like it's
okay like I know I know I shouldn't do
this because I'll probably get burnt out
but it's fine I'll do it on this
occasion because when I get burned up
that's fine it'll be over in two weeks
and then I'll be it'll be okay again so
I would love to say that I sit here and
get up early in journal and I go for a
run every morning to clear my head
before I have my iced latte and you know
set the day straight but
that's not true that is uh purely
because I've listened to too many
podcasts I know what's the right thing
to say is
um so I think that I don't have any good
structures to avoid burnout
um I have been burnt out in the past
and I probably am going to be burnt out
a few more times in the future but I'm
still I think I'm too focused on that
first Mountain analogy that we're
looking at I'm too focus on the summit
of that first mountain and I've got
blisters all over my feet but my my eye
shoes are determined to get to the top
um which again is probably a very
worrying thing to say and I've already
looked back on this this interview in
like three years time and just be like
you were an absolute idiot that's a sign
of growth and but I am constantly
looking for I think I just don't
prioritize the the things that will stop
burnout
um why
because I don't think that I don't I
don't value them and I don't value them
highly enough I don't think that they
have I can't see the objective value of
of them so therefore I don't think they
are worth the time which I know and then
but then the vague thing is like taking
time off yeah
I then just I took I went on holidays
for two weeks after I did the Edinburgh
Fringe run I was like right let's take
some time off for two weeks and I was
just thinking about the channel the
whole time like what am I like this is
this is rubbish like I've gone away to
like have some time away but no I'm not
enjoying this time away I was most
happiest when I was doing The Fringe
actually because I was like I wasn't
thinking about the channel I was just
thinking about every day and let's do my
show and that's it and I could I could
compartmentalize things a little bit
better yeah yeah I find the whole sort
of taking time off thing is also
massively overrated
um in that whenever I take time off I'm
like great the Calendar's empty now I
can write the book properly or now I can
like plan out this video that I've had
in my mind for ages and haven't had time
to to think about
um the way I do I do holidays is usually
trying to trying to do something that
looks like work for at least a few hours
because then it gets out of my system
and then I can enjoy the Sunset Cruise
or the high court or whatever rather
than feeling like I haven't thought
about a video for a while any any advice
you'd give to aspiring creators yes get
good at making videos which is that you
think is like be good at it
um or at least be good at what you know
you can be good at
um because I think often people are so
determined to find hacks and cheats with
YouTube and just any job that ultimately
comes down with can you provide value
through a video to somebody are you
making them laugh are you educating them
are you entertaining them if you're
answering to that question yes then
great and the best way to do that is by
making videos
um someone will say oh I've made three
videos and can you what do you think
could you give me some advice about what
I should do next I always say okay just
make 50. make 50 and then decide whether
you still want to do this and if
nothing's working after 50 and you're
not seeing any growth at all then that's
a clear sign that maybe you shouldn't be
doing this Niche maybe you should be
going somewhere else I don't agree that
YouTube is too saturated and that you
can't start a YouTube career now that's
absolutely rubbish I think anybody can
still you can there are people now with
10 subscribers who will have 10 million
subscribers in three years time that's
definitely true whether you do that
through shorts whether you go through
long form is a different conversation
um and depending on the quality of the
audience that you want to have
um yeah don't get me don't understand
that sounds okay Rabbit Hole yeah I'll
start seeing I'll start to get quite um
yeah we've got a framework that we have
for our YouTube course and stuff which
is level one is get going level two is
get good level threes get smart yeah and
get smart is where you worry about your
Niche and stuff yeah and people are
often like way too like oh my God is
this the right like how am I gonna start
it's like look just get good at making a
video yeah once you once you can do that
once a week then or whatever consistency
you want at that point let's talk about
your nation and retention tactics and
all of that crap that what thumbnail
you're gonna use
um so no I completely I would completely
agree with that uh that methodology so
excellent we've got the have fun with
this approval all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode episode here
as well which links in with some of the
stuff that we talked about in the
episode so thanks for watching uh do hit
the Subscribe button if you aren't
already and I'll see you next time bye